you
you
I
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast the Millennial morning
show how are you doing today I'm fine
I had like a long day and honestly
actually I went to a she or last night
which is like a Bible study for people
who don't notice or like whatever I
think of Bible study I think of Tamra of
course but so Lydia okay forget yes so
it's like the same thing for Jewish
people but like with the Old Testament
and it was so inspiring and so uplifting
and honestly I go to them I can use I
used to go once a week now I go like
once a month because I'm just like bad
about it but I have a hard time
following because like some are my eyes
are like a little all over the place but
that's like their shtick it's like
tangential AF they're more tangential
than the show by the way and the rabbi
was extremely toasty like I just could
tell he would like our show he was like
he was getting distracted by everything
at cuz people like her so rude coming in
late and he was like every time someone
would come in he would be distracted I'm
like throw it off and honestly I was
feeling so tired and I was like I can't
go I can't go but I told my friend Lisa
at her house was like I'm gonna go so me
and then went and like it was the
greatest thing ever you know I would say
we sit in the toast and we feel tired
then we do the chose me feel amazing hmm
I was feeling so tired and groggy I
almost fell asleep at the start and then
after the class I was like reinvigorated
by God and I was like this is why I was
meant to come and it's such an important
lesson I couldn't really go into it
right now cuz I it was very long gist
just is like okay actually it was really
interesting and I you were told us about
this and that you wanted to talk about
it tonight at dinner and so I don't want
spoiler alert for me cuz I do want to
hear the other thing but just us what's
the message what should we take away oh
it's Friday morning it was a great she
or given what had happened last week and
he was just like I feel like we now need
to like be unified as Jews and but he
was like what like besides from blood
like what are characteristics that make
up like a good Jew and people were like
throwing out like kindness you know like
things like that and they're all good
answers I gave one to I was like
compassion you know like you're making
fun of other people dinner I was in the
weenie and like that was what he was
looking for he was like no not really
he basically went on to say that there
are three pillars of what it needs to be
like a good Jew in just because you're
Jewish doesn't mean you have these
pillars and just because we're these
pillars doesn't mean there are three
pillars the first yeah what you want to
guess maybe okay sure I do you think
that I that I will they're like out
yeah okay I think one of them is charity
oh my god that's the first one very good
okay so the thing is what he said is
like what is charity it's like um it's a
reactive thing like you see something
sad and you feel obligated or like you
merciful and you you donate or whatever
but in this [ __ ] bug it's like the
episode of Breaking Bad there's a fly
I've never even seen Breaking Bad I just
know there's one episode it's a terrible
episode okay but so if you're Jewish in
the Bible it's actually written you have
to give ten percent of your income every
year to charity it's not like a thing
that you like can do it's an obligation
you don't opt-in right it's not right
it's not avoiding taxes exactly so given
the intent of taxes forty 40 percent of
taxes and Rizzo charity where's my money
okay whatever so he was like that's part
of being like a good G was like feeling
like it's not even a question like you
just you do it like this it's a part of
life and that's like the more like it's
kind of like the right side of brain
left side of brain like number one is
like just generosity compassion feeling
for others but not only like you can
only give charity to people like you
like if you only feel bad for and um
like associate with fellow Jewish people
or fellow people similar to like you and
you're just as bad as an animal that's
what I said unless you feel compassion
and give charity and do good things for
all kinds of people then doesn't count
okay so just as that there's no point in
doing good we need to diversify our
charity for it exactly but then the
right side which is where you're gonna
love this part okay so what was the
second uh Miller I think a second pillar
would be like to uh like for like
self-awareness no no strength you're
right
so number and then I stick it this is
strength was like the opposite of
charity like strength is like even in
the worst times Jews have been through
the war be like emotionally strong
serious I'd like to always think that
there's a future and then he brought
someone up and I was freaking out and he
started saying and I said I know who
you're talking about because I don't
know if you guys know this Jackie and I
are descendants of an extremely famous
rabbi prominent prestigious
I we learned about him AAS we learned
about him in the eighth grade as a man's
rabbi aphromoo shrine and he's from
Lithuania and in the Holocaust he was
like the rabbi of the ghetto they were
keeping everyone in the Warsaw at
versailles ghetto and people would come
to him and be like hey like it's the
it's technically like Hanukkah right now
but we don't have any candles like how
do we do
traditions it's called Halawa but
they're like how do we keep our Jewish
traditions in these hard times right and
he would literally like give people like
ways to keep like Shabbat and all these
things even though they literally didn't
have like a piece of bread to make a
busing over and he would write down all
the the rules that he made up and bury
them in the ground of the Warsaw Ghetto
in these milk cans and years later they
took it out and they wrote it all in
this book called responsa but did you
know actually that some of those milk
cans are still buried but they're buried
on the grounds of the Chinese embassy
and the Chinese won't let us get them
come on like what nerve it's just a milk
M what does it mean to you honey that
should be our life's work you know what
when I heard it I was like how did I not
know that how we are the I'll share
legacy right and if we can't do it who
can okay we'll figure that out China
you'll be hearing what am i said about
that there were also rabbis there who
were like writing down what was
happening to them like for history and
burying it in case anyone ever found it
but the difference was that Rabbi ashrae
was writing down like what to do for the
future generations like if you're ever
whatever here's the best way to keep the
traditions meaning that like even though
if you're in the ghetto and they're
killing all your people you're not
thinking of future generations you're
thinking like this is the end of
survival right but so the idea that the
future of the Jews was impossible wasn't
a possibility to Rabbi ashtray and like
that's what that's a strength that Jews
mean it's like people are always trying
to kill us they're always coming for us
I'm a lake everyone's always trying to
throw us out of what every country we've
ever been in people are trying throw us
out but we outlive our enemies okay
sucks it's extreme you see like kindness
and love compassion and through anything
great no third the third you're talking
like I'll bet I know and the door you
can't say these things without talking
like a robot we should have a rabbi on
this show one time check and maybe
because he's toast he's young and
actually wasn't young he looked young if
he was like kinda hot and he had five
daughters when I was 18 I'm like oh
she's totally a toaster and he's like
the new rabbi in town so like they were
like welcoming him in a rabbi in town
okay so the third pillar is a balance of
1 & 2 1 plus 2 equals 3 so the third is
truth so basically what he was saying is
like you can't be an extreme of one and
an extreme of two like no good you is it
it's like you have to live your life
balance between persevering through
strength but also it's taking time to
think of others right okay the end is
like a little for Clementine I think you
should live your truth essentially but
in better words that I wrote down and
then I'll read later tonight I look
forward to it it was such a wonderful
class and like sometimes like I just
can't follow and he was just making it
easy one two three like that I can
follow you know yeah I really enjoyed it
I'm happy for you thanks for the invite
yeah also I just feel like all those
things but I excuse me I didn't bite
everyone in the challenge because left
in the chat last night blessed week
because last night Elise his brother was
like when your sisters coming I'm like
why didn't they come today I invite them
and then I remembered that I wrote it in
the chat what lbc invited me so he must
have been a busy night for the child
cause I didn't see it cuz usually I I
try to come back oh and it was a good
one cuz it was at Alicia's house and
Alicia's mom makes the greatest food and
she made mini pizzas that were just like
to die for
and she's Kim Kardashian's number one
fans like she couldn't get over that I
met Kim she wants to smell me oh my god
did she watch the episode of the toast
where we dress up as Kardashian's I
don't know she's very busy that episode
it's great because like even if you're
not a toaster like everyone has seen
that site at some point of course so
everyone can really express Chegg
relatable and like the good thing about
yours is like it's the old testament so
like a lot of people can join you got to
be Jewish yeah no totally even Lydia's
Bible class Lydia and Tamara I
understand you talk about Old Testament
- yes like Matthew and his friends that
I don't know that's later on yeah yeah
yeah but it's um happy Friday we made it
brother
this is how the longest week ever well
even though we didn't do a show on
Monday every Monday we you were coming
back from LA I was uh sleeping until 3
o'clock after my trip to Austin oh right
and then Tuesday you did a show okay so
it's been a long week for me but it's
only been like three shows so like I'll
live right and then yesterday we
recorded a bonus episode of it - yeah
we're gonna release it because we have a
choppy couple weeks so we're really
trying to get our all of our bases
covered we have joey camasta next week
covering for me and then also there's
another oh the Monday after ladies
bachelorette party we are not gonna be
here but we've recorded like a 50 minute
episode with Melissa Gorga yesterday
that will release for that and it was so
premium I loved her so mom I love her so
much she's the coolest woman alive she's
first of all like so annoyingly skinny
and gorgeous like I wanted to I and she
had been up all day doing press like we
did with her at 5 o'clock when we were
her last thing
the day and she was just like so
beautiful still even though she did her
makeup at nine o'clock you know totally
and she says something on the podcast
that spoiler that really like resonated
woodsy about how much she's changed into
the show started and I as a viewer I
agree as a viewer I agree I feel like
she's so like herself and and confident
in herself like it's really nice to see
like someone on the show who's changed
for the better
mm-hmm for good people want to know why
you look so nice okay so this is why you
didn't tell your sister that you're
gonna look nice because her your sister
actually actually bought her first pair
of slacks with a bell bottom yesterday
and she would have worn them had she
known that you were gonna wear a
crocodile heel and a puppy shoulder I
understand I understand
I hear you this is a businesswoman
special episode of the show because I
have a luncheon after the show and I
just I wanted to look like a lady who
lunches and I was gonna bring a change
of clothes and put this on after the
show but I was like why don't the
toasters what I should wear a
piece-of-shit t-shirt and sneakers are
the toasters
why wouldn't I give them my Friday best
are you saying that's what I'm know you
considering I didn't tell you you look
very perfect I happen to put on actually
what happened to me today and the reason
why I didn't tell you is because I
thought maybe I would change and it's
like you don't need to hear about all of
the decisions that go on in my mind and
it wasn't until this morning when I
tried the dress on and I couldn't take
it off because I would've gotten makeup
on it that I was stuck in it okay that I
understand but you know a heads-up would
have been nice because I actually had an
interesting time getting ready this
morning as you know for most of my life
I only wore leggings as pants and I
would say maybe two years ago I
transitioned to jeans their aging
journey jeans only top shop brand like I
think where it's Jenny jeans are weird
and like they just don't work for
everyone and I like that the Topshop
jeans you can choose your width but also
your length
so for someone who is big they assume
that I have a long leg as well which I
don't so I get the shortest leg and like
one of the bigger waist but also the
good thing about Topshop jeans is I
really think they are made for models
but they have a line of Jamie jeans that
are meant to be capris for models but on
short girls it's the perfect laying
skinny jean exactly but when I went to
blue meet the first time I keep talking
about Bloomingdale's personal shopping
and I have a point when I did Bert blew
me up Bloomingdale's dropping our tank
yes
you look like Lauri Grenier you wanna
know something so weird about this dress
and the sweater I wore yesterday weirdly
guess who makes both items you're never
gonna guess oh no Juicy Couture this is
bird by Juicy Couture which was their
like couture line for a minute but my
sweater from yesterday everyone was
asking was Juicy Couture with the pink
label like made with love P&G
made in the USA like that's the Jimmy
Mizrahi effect she's the new uh she's a
new creative director and she's robbed
these are items like from the early
2000s sexist our classics it's so cute
it's so cute anyways I will invest in
your business make me a deal I can't I
can't refuse
the first time I ever did Bloomingdale's
person stupid [ __ ] anecdote three
talking this is what I should have been
wearing in the elevator at Daymond John
a hundred percent except you were barely
naked on your way back from
skinny-dipping in the ocean at midnight
right so I'm glad I he has no clue who I
am yeah we don't need that kind of
representation for our brand yeah the
first time you know it is very hundred
how does it feel
I'm sorry the first time I ever did
Bloomingdale's personal shopping
Bloomingdale's
I was doing a partnership at the
registry when I got an email that they
want me on the Taoiseach of the next
morning and I was like freaking out and
the women who worked in the registry
they were like we have personal shopping
like let us call town and go down a
tower that was the first time I ever
heard about personal shopping and I
literally have never went back to
Bloomingdale's since without him and I
went and she picked out this outfit for
me and we we ended up with this like
velvet blazer and these jeans was the
first time I ever wore jeans I'm like I
can't wear leggings on the Today Show
and they were like these J Brand Jeans
that like barely fit I was dying like
literally suffocating and they stayed in
my closet I never wore them again
because they only were Topshop jeans
today I am wearing the jeans and I'm not
gonna lie they're a little big that's
amazing it's such a big feel like oh and
then I put on this shirt that I was like
gonna wear for the first time in
literally five years and I was like
feeling myself until I realize there was
like a huge stain on it which is just
like the soundtrack of my life and it
was like ink it was blue like it was not
coming shiny vibes only day dives all
depends what the scene is and my thing
with stains is like if I have one away
or something it has a scene like all
I'll do is just go out like be with
people be like oh my god like I just
seen my dress like rat yeah not like I'm
wearing something crazy ain't smart yeah
also I did something so terrifying
yesterday and I went to a new tailor and
dry cleaner and like I brought them a
number of items and just pray for me
it's all I can ask for okay
can you imagine no but I need it to like
in my you are cleaning is not dry
cleanings not that hard but tailoring
like that new star
in there but like it's just a habit I
know but like I need it they took it in
a little bit too but I needed a tailor
in my neighborhood like I can't keep
going uptown every time you know but I
have a good one you do yeah we're in my
new neighborhood oh it's really good but
I'm like I'm so funny I looked at the
Yelp reviews after I dropped after I
gave them everything okay I'm sorry I
will never ever take the up at face
value because nobody has a premium
experience and their first thought is to
write a positive yelp review maybe
they'll tell their friends about it but
like you only really want to destroy it
and hurt a business when you've had a
negative experience and everyone like no
no business is perfect and I'm not gonna
lie Yelp makes it so hard to write a
review because they want to make sure
you're not like your own business
writing business reviews about your own
business so it's like the one time I've
actually had a positive experience and
like felt like I should do the right
thing and write a positive yelp review
they made it so hard for me and I don't
think I even got approved so it has it
pens like a doesn't you don't write it
and it post like it appends approval and
I'm like and then everyone throw right
and like you can't even look at all the
reviews unless you download their app
and that's just never gonna happen I
think that is probably one of the
biggest mistakes Yelp has made this
business it's like we're on your phone
on their app on your phone you cannot
open up because when you go to Google
Maps and you want to scroll through
photos if you click it it takes you to
Yelp and Yelp takes you to the Yelp app
store for the Yelp app but I'm not
buying the El PAP and never no longer
interested in the photos but if you just
stir I send me to a website you could
have made add money off of me ya know
it's at such a poor decision and I can't
believe that they haven't evolved yeah
also this is like the longest I've been
home I will have been home for a week
straight like I haven't been home for a
week trying to tell ya it feels so great
and now I'm like it's like I haven't
spent a lot of time in my new apartment
and now like that I'm spending so much
time I'm like realizing how much I hate
like the limited furniture I've bought
so like this week I'm just like going
apeshit on decor because I'm I
discovered like to know it and I've
always seen these like thirsty bloggers
with the like to know it [ __ ] but I
felt someone told me about this girl
that Dacor died at Jackie she lives in
Dallas our house is so [ __ ] cute I
miss the decor Diane yeah that's how I
started screenshotting everything that
she got and she's always like - no
eating it and I'm like okay let me just
download this stupid app and see if it
works and if it's easy and all my
screenshots automatically uploaded and
they just like sent me links to I
literally bought like a million trays
and Baz is that she owns trays dawes's
and
are really like the unsung heroes of
home decor who especially candles
because one they smell amazing and they
look so pretty and then when you burn
through the candle the vols leaned out
the Boz and now it's my new makeup
holder couldn't agree more and I love
all different candles but there are
certain actually that's not true I'm
very particular when it comes to sense
in the home like me too I have to smell
everything in the story then I got a
headache and I don't get anything but
there are a few like amazing campus
create a scent profile but I don't know
what that is no it's whatever you want
it to be but I don't know what I want it
to be like I just want the right scent
to hit me across the face right like I
want someone to walk into my house and
be like oh she's warm kind and rich
right or I want someone would be like
this scent smells like a bunch on the
fourth of July home this scent smells
like home this scent smells like the
holidays yeah yeah I love a holiday
candle I love a holiday candle do uh do
you know homesick candles I did where'd
like they're by state yeah and like the
end country - they're like a literally a
million that's so cool actually that's
funny that you mentioned exercise just
got a homesick candle for Zach he
doesn't want to show you so it's a
surprise but it's nice that we can talk
about things without our husbands
finding out because they don't watch our
show it's that nice it's very nice and I
got him it obviously Texas million
candle cuz you know I he wouldn't admit
it to me but he was it a little like
okay read the description head back to
Texas with this fragrance reminiscent of
dark leather fresh pine and OH and thick
lemon slices Oh a floral note of
cyclamen and a touch of sage help
balance the big bold sense of the Lone
Star State you know zach is nothing but
a big bold guy no he's never served a
big bolt handle for homesick and also
I'm excited for him to sniff it tell you
what he smells and then I also got a
holiday candle because I love the
holidays and I love a beach cottage
candle that smells like like sandalwood
and and the ocean and sunscreen yeah
sunscreen it smells amazing smells
amazing so I love the channel site just
got all these ones from home sick
candles and I'm so excited to implement
them in the home as as Jewish people we
can't do like wreaths and like all the
Christmas steak or than everyone else
can a Christmas tree that smells like
pie so we we resort to candles these or
two candles and you know if you can -
you can - with homesick candles right
now our listeners who go to home sick
come and use promo code toast will
receive 10% off any order over $50 and
get free shipping
that's a great deal 10% off and free
shipping this amazing offer in the most
popular state and city candles won't
last long so don't wait
just visit homesick calm now using promo
code toast find a great personal gift
for your whole holiday list today here
for it I'm so behind on my gifts and I
only have one person I need to get a
gift for and I'm already behind
vo oh [ __ ] I forgot about it whoo oh
yeah I thought like you were about to
make a joke no it's hard to know when a
comedian is gonna make a joke oh my god
you know emoji new napkin
no it's black it's okay it's a good it's
a good material - just a little bit of
dry mouth can I have a sip of your
coffee Wow oh my god
Wow this paper cup is it's actually you
know what it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy
I got a stain today in the dress don't
believe it now when I go talk to
everyone Oh a stain major actually this
was a mud rose this um are you trying to
steal my coffee no I was just to put
anyone to this material really is like
microfiber Mike just wipe it away a lot
happened in the news yesterday so
without further ado it would be my honor
my privilege and my blessing to deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
okay first story it's so funny we keep
talking about how we're no longer I'm
gonna talk about Pete and Arianna which
also pauses briefly I want to give a
shout out do you know that this weekend
is a camp to us reunion in Asheville yes
and they made sweatshirts and they're
like so cute and having the best time
and I don't know why they couldn't wait
til literally week and a half when we're
gonna be in Nashville right but when
this works for everyone and you know
sometimes mom and dad don't need to be
around to write and they planned it like
they had their [ __ ] together and you
know we kind of cobble things together
with minutes and which is a great time
to mention that camp those tickets will
be coming out very soon so start
scrounging your money together should we
tell them how much it is just so people
can start saving us saving up to be
decide yeah what remind me so much of
cam toasts to Memorial Day weekend it's
a three-day weekend full of fun-filled
Sun toasty vibes new friends etc and if
you are skeptical feel free to ask
someone who's been to camp toast just so
they can tell you how magical it is
maybe Samantha Wayne is available maybe
my best friend search hashtag camp toast
on Instagram for all of the premium
content once you get to camp toast
everything is there for you gourmet
food we couldn't attest that last time
because we said it would just be like
fat camp food but it was literally it
was hotel level more omelet our pasta
stations carving stations every meal was
like we didn't stop eating no and Lane
were working out so much breakfast and
stuff like there was no breakfast meal
that wasn't an option like omelets
bagels muffins bacon sausage everything
every day so and unlimited alcohol as
you know because it wouldn't be nothing
if not toasty so we're gearing up for
chem toast you should too
tickets are 625 tickets are 650 dollars
fifty eight so should we tell them when
they're going on sale do we know when
they're going on so actually you know
what wait everything will be available
before the holidays though so if you're
getting it for someone as a gift a great
gift idea yeah and just start and we
have we've a good amount of time we are
going to cap it this year because I
think we liked in the number where it
was at we're not trying to make it like
a million people because we want to be
able to like hang out with everyone
everyone gets to know us us get to know
that um it's gonna be really premium and
there will be karaoke so it's literally
all you need to know yeah karaoke
everything is karaoke I can toast no
it's like we had evening activities
planned every night in some reason like
they rose up their water bottles with
wine and it turned into karaoke and you
know it we're not gonna try and stop it
and then it's like just the message of
the toast it's like no matter where we
are who we are we just always end up
singing and dancing and I love that no I
love it
and yes per usual Pete remembers we'll
get first access to tickets patreon.com
slash the morning toast there's some
premium content up there now and
November is gonna be a big month for
patreon because we're taking off
Thanksgiving week but we'll be with our
family creating premium content you
don't want to miss it
patreon.com slash your morning toast but
we're really getting in all of our
housekeeping today yeah anything else Oh
tickets to my show are still available
girl with no job com I'm finishing out
the year with shows in Charlotte next
week first one a sold out second one is
about to be sold out and that's when TPG
is going to so I suggest you get your
tickets now after that I will be in
Birmingham Alabama we're gonna be in
Nashville and then I'm finishing out the
year in Miami which I heard last night
is 90% sold out and I haven't even
spoken about it yet cuz you guys found
the link and are crazy and that's why I
love you totally oh my god water yeah my
dry mouth on the mic thank you so much
that is so nice pretty generous also I
had one more announcement to make but I
can't remember
I think it had to do with your shows
maybe a little Miami I'm working on
coming to your Miami show so that should
really boost ticket sales but Jackie
keeps saying she's coming places and
then doesn't come and disappoint you
keep saying incoming places and then
like something comes up and Cuddy is
like good but I didn't want you to come
anyway but you did ask me to come to
Miami Sebastian's throw an end of year
party and honestly we deserve it no and
like I'm inviting everyone invited my
friends Eric and John and Daniela are
trying to come like I'm really trying to
get everyone to come yeah and we just
like we should throw an end-of-the-year
party we've had a hell of a year we've
had this has been the crazy look like
I'm leaving like roller coasters and
involuntarily been on one for like eight
months no totally oh and you're getting
off I'm so tired and you're getting on a
new one that has us loop-de-loops yes
more of a completely new more of one
who's control but it's like here's the
thing about world look like life being a
roller coaster like you want to be on
the upright mm-hmm but inevitably it
goes down right well I guess cuz you die
I guess but that's a long up that's a
scary young art that's a whole other she
or she or is the Bible class sorry tour
class yeah okay first story Arianna and
P we're just gonna keep updating you on
the minutiae of their relationship
because the whole world is so interested
and so mine but this isn't minutia and I
have strong opinions on it and I don't
feel the need to talk about every time
like she flashes her ring and she's like
still wearing the bandaid on her finger
like that I don't care about okay
Ariana Grande shades Pete Davidson /
joke about their failed engagement
perhaps their breakup isn't as amicable
as fans thought ariana grande shaded
Pete Davidson on Twitter Thursday night
after his promo for this weekend's SNL
with Jonah Hill aired online in the
promo Davidson pokes fun at his failed
engagement to the God is a woman singer
by proposing to musical guest Maggie
Rogers who's Maggie Rogers hey Maggie
watching it and she was so pretty and
I'm like who the hell is Maggie I don't
know but I've heard her name before it
hey Maggie I'm Pete you want to get
married Davidson says in the clip as
this weekend's host he'll kill cringed
Rogers 24 declines in Davidson responds
by saying he's over three poking fun and
his failed relationships which includes
Cassie David then Ariana Grande took to
Twitter and said for somebody who claims
to hate relevancy you sure love clinging
to it huh so when I saw that tweet I was
like yes it's fired off and then I did
research because I want to see what it
was related to and I have to say I do
think it was like a bit of an
overreaction that's like she had a good
disk and wanted to use it for something
but like they were flaunting their
relationship on SNL like when it was at
its best so it's only right
that they talked about it being over and
it's not he didn't bring up Ariana at
all he was really talking about himself
and as much as I'm totally on Ariana
side just like in life I thought she
overreacted too because I think what he
did was so bad and it was like poking
fun at himself not at him and not at her
or their relationship I don't think was
a big deal you know what I have to agree
with you when people like go so hard
with their relationship and then it's
over and you want to pretend like it
never happened even though you did not
stop shoving it down our throats it's
like no shove the bike shove the
break-up down our throats to like you
can't just pretend like it never happen
yeah I appreciate this self-awareness
also justice for Carly Aquilino who
dated Pete Davidson before Kathy David
and isn't even a part of this now and it
wasn't included in oh-for-three she's
ready included in even though they were
like so serious for so long I'm gonna
toe forgot about that right I'm still
hurting out hope for her and quits to
Stefano
they were both on girlcode and they were
like so cute and like my memory girlcode
was the greatest thing ever
yes what happened make new episodes we
by the way if girl code was around now
like I feel like we might have like on
an audition for it oh for sure yeah
cuz he had to us but he was going so
well what happened I don't know and then
they had guy code and like so many
amazing aegyo came first and that's
where Charlene came from
well surely much is not know something
to be alive but yes sir like he was
there before Nicole Byer came from yes
Martin Maher Cocoa's did she know who
Nicole Byer was that makes sense
no it doesn't it does because when we
were watching a girl code that was like
Jackie that's where awkwafina came from
no yes
not came from like they all had careers
before like I was there springboard yeah
no everyone who was there like really is
doing so well for themselves
I know good for you guys no the Carly
Aquilino of it all it was so funny
mm-hm and so real I guess like that's
what memes are now you know total if
you're watching girl code before we had
memes I liked a girl speaking of MTV I
caught up on are either one which you
know soldiers and I found myself and
some are you the one drama because one
of the cast members screenshot of my
story like because I said why is
everyone sleeping on Utah this season is
horrible the cast is horrible the
casting is atrocious there is one girl
who is the cutest prettiest funniest
smartest person ever and like no one
will be with her she's literally
beautiful I don't know so I was like why
is everyone especially Brett sleeping on
newts a-- he's screenshotted it and then
wrote the star sleeping with o at Jackie
O problems and I was like oh my god what
like what does that even mean but then
he was like no that time I meant like
he's been sleeping with new - like
sleeping next I don't know I found
myself in drama and they did not like it
and I'm T new to forever because there's
literally no oh I'm watching Netflix now
there's no other there's no other choice
ya know like sometimes I like become
thirsty and like a start Instagram drama
and then it starts and I'm like wow I
really shouldn't do this no it's like
then they're gonna come for me yeah
they're gonna start going through my
[ __ ] like oh god yeah you know what like
my picture is like tearing me apart like
totally I'm okay sad face I would like
to be excluded from this narrative one
which I never asked to be brought up
since 2000 done okay next story is
really well it's shocking depending on
who you are
we'd started something out there just
really quickly about this narrative
mm-hmm
I've been trying to keep it a secret but
like I keep hinting at it and like I'm
really just over trying to stop lying
about it I'm starting to Taylor Swift
consider this serious C theory podcast
and it can't come up with a good name
like I wanted to be a play on words I
wanted to have the name Swift in it
I have like two options that I don't
even like like if you have any good
ideas that's like a play on some of her
lyrics or like something about a
narrative I don't know just tweet me
please I really need help so I guess
that's you telling me you didn't like
any of my choices no and I asked you for
an explanation I money you just didn't
respond to me because you're supposed to
be her number one fan and it was did you
mean that the last last word but I
always get the last word that's too
specific
Oh think about it it just needs to be a
name yeah I wanna take a lyric from long
live okay
kings and queens I know but it's just
like that could be about the royal
family like then it could become the
long live podcast like whatever oh
that's pretty sweet a name like and then
you just start and no and that I can't
start without a name and now I'm talking
about it so much I know someone's gonna
steal my idea so get on it
I know [ __ ] this okay next story is not
talking if you're in the morning
toasters group but I'm still a little
shocked by it because I didn't believe
that it was true
inu Zee online exclusive why Kaitlyn
Bristowe and Shawn booth could be headed
for a split is there trouble in paradise
for Kaitlyn and Shawn two months after
the Bachelorette star shut down rumors
of a possible split between her and her
fiance of more than three years multiple
sources are telling a news that Kaitlyn
and Shawn are working through quote
major issues in their relationship
between demanding work schedules Shawn
just opened his very own first fitness
facility called booth camp and he's such
a good name and Kaitlyn continues to
host her off the vine podcast and
differing passions
we're told they've been quote spending a
lot of time apart while deciding what's
next for the future of their engagement
quote they technically live together but
they barely see or spend time together
anymore one source tells E news it's
been a rough couple of months for them
and they've been trying to figure out
their balance but it just isn't working
so this whole story is based on source
telling a very secondary sources and as
a history major I don't immediately
trust them but this is why I'm on my
phone where there is smoke there might
be fire
so there a news posted a picture of
Kaitlyn and Shawn and whenever they post
a picture like a couple or like an old
person you're like oh they're dead or
they're dead so they wrote exclusive the
bachelorettes Kaitlyn Bristowe and Shawn
boots are struggling with major issues
in their relationship Lincoln bio
so that to me is like just the most
misleading piece of what's the word with
an S sensationalize like sensationalized
piece of news like that made it seem
like exclusive Kaitlyn spoke to us and
we know everything but then it's like
I'm like oh [ __ ] and I ran over I hit
the Lincoln bio meaty like yeah I'm like
you just basically wrote up everything
the toasters have been saying for like
the past two months and yeah speculation
that they haven't been hanging out on in
real life and that they're both really
busy like great we knew that too like
you just put it in an article and
pretended it was an exclusive we have
eyes they're not exclusively the ones
who can see right I thought
gonna be testimonial from her podcast
like direct from the source like I
really wasn't expecting this secondary
source drivel but maybe they know
something that they can't say which is
why they're going off of these rumors
well I mean I don't know anything I'm
like I really hope it's not true because
they're like literally my favorite
people separately and also together and
they're just so beautiful
but the toasters are like convinced that
they're not together because she hasn't
been wearing her ring and then they've
been a lot separated a lot but then
she's addressed it she's like oh I'm not
wearing my ring because Sean wants to
repurpose in a way that's not on TV
which is really cute so I'm like okay so
it's fine yes just conflicting she said
this on her podcast I think it's made of
been a few months ago though quote we
are both so busy and unfortunately that
means we are spending all of this time
apart if you've ever been a person who
was running a successful brand or
business and with someone who was doing
the same but in a different career path
you know that times can be tough you're
both always away you're exhausted at the
end of the day sometimes the
relationship isn't being put first but
does that mean oh you call it quits
no you love the [ __ ] out of each other
and you work through it and you work on
yourselves to be better and you know
that times aren't always going to be
smooth sailing you know that times
aren't always going to be tough you know
what I think it is I think like in the
beginning of their relationship like
Kaitlyn like really took off her podcast
is so popular like people love her she
has like a legit business and like Sean
was really like supportive in there for
her and I think that and by the way this
is just a speculation I know nothing to
be to be true but like now it's like he
wants it to be about him and like that
shifts the dynamic I mean I don't even
know what I'm saying but I just think
that like I really hope they're not
broken up like I'll be really sad
because I feel like them being together
like they proved a point yeah to the
networks I don't know what the point was
but it was like they were proving the
point no they they were like the real
the real couple of The Bachelor because
everyone else has these fairytale
experiences and you know you know it's
them until the end but like her season
was very tumultuous like a lot of ups
and downs they almost like went through
like a real relationship in the time of
her season and then like she also has
just she does have to prove to EBC
because like she can only they can
always you know they can ignore her all
they want but the proof is in the
pudding and the fact that her and Sean
are real it's like why don't we get a TV
wedding why don't we get it right they
give the all the attention and all the
money to the most annoying bachelor
couples who never work out it's like
there's one real couple who are going
through real [ __ ] and like we'll never
give us any of them like
they let everything we know about them
we know through her podcast or their
instagrams like through then like not
through ABC because ABC like hates wheel
couples no hates real couples and they
like they go they promote couples I got
the wrong time right right now like they
should be promoting Jojo and Jordan
because like they have lasted you know
and Rachel and Brian are so real but of
course like ABC just like once everyone
to think that she's in love with you
yeah it's a Venera t'v that they never
asked apart okay uh like can't keep it
ABC cannot give up their false
narratives and I'm not here for it but I
don't know I feel like there's
definitely something going on because
they aren't spending a lot of time
together uh-huh
wait soso fiel I said this is a quote
from Kaitlyn's podcast I'm not even
wearing my ring anymore are you still
considered my fiancee I guess not but
now you're my boyfriend that's weird
what a step down I guess because the
reaper posle which i thought was cute
it's like the special moment looking at
a proposal I don't know but they love
their special woman they didn't in their
way at the bachelor mansion ooh yeah
literally that's people the two of them
it would have been somewhere else like
yeah you know what I mean because ABC
hated them they thought they were doing
them like dirty by making them go back
to the bachelor mansion which is like
where they fell in love and they loved
it right I don't know I'm really sad
like I really hope that everything's
okay and this is all just speculation
I hope so too I feel like if it was just
speculation like she would have
addressed it head-on by now but she did
a few months ago and I feel like they
really they're not addressing it and
they're not conceding because they're
really trying to make it work which like
I respected them and I feel like all
they really want is privacy so let's
leave it alone boo but rumors are
swirling so we reported it but I'm
really hoping for you know what that's
the tough part of the job yeah I'm
really pulling for them we do I think
they can I think and what about the dog
the dog was Shan Shan's but like but
like the dog is with Kaitlyn every time
I see kids in Scripture she's at Tucker
so I mean they're really worried about I
can't even imagine like I mean like a
million times god forbid a million times
me and then like break up I mean it's
never gonna happen by god forbid another
times like the other made of course like
he was my idea
of course okay I'm like and he has died
he is three on sneakers yes I know I
would die he would die but God forbid
million times like I would like poo poo
poo poo of course of course
next story is a little spooky Kenny
Ortega says Michael Jackson quote
whispers in his ear Michael Jackson is
speaking from the dead according to the
King of Pop's close friend and
choreographer Kenny Ortega oh my god he
was his core us and like I mean I love
you tango and like you can't speak a bad
word about him both people have but
snitch will not be okay okay he is the
choreographer such a musical school
musical the Hannah Montana best of both
worlds
tour right like in Disney descendants in
Disney's heyday Kenny Ortega I was like
the creative director of everything
really Joey still is but like he's do
what he does descendants but people
don't relate to Disney now like they did
like they did back then anything that
has to do with the musical he's not only
the choreographer he's the director of
everything so so musical like he's the
one who put Miley in that pool dancing
scene at the end of High School Musical
2 and like just she was in them yes
she's just like dancing by the pool that
is the move High School Musical who says
we have to let it go to the moocher were
saying different songs quote Michael is
here 24/7 and always here whispering in
my ear I mean he is indelible he is
forever he is alive in spirit with me
always Ortega said at the eighth annual
world of choreography Awards Wow cares
we weren't invited there really isn't a
word so for everything no by the way the
world of choreography Awards literally
the only people who go are Kenny Ortega
and Jenna Dewan
she hosts he picks up the abort um
Ortega choreography at grasp Jackson's
this is it tour before the icon passed
away from a Popa fall overdose how do
you feel about Michael Jackson I feel
like his memory is that kind of weird no
it's the way people talk about him it's
weird because if he were still alive
like he would be such a pariah because
like what he did to children is right so
he was but so they said he didn't do it
so like legally it's like said he didn't
do it he wasn't convicted he was no I'd
literally remember being in the car as a
six year old that I knew nothing that
was going on and they turned up the
radio and everyone was listening and it
was like Michael Jackson not fealty so
it's like there's no proof that he did
it even though everyone and the blinds
know that like he would had Neverland
Ranch where like children used to go but
I just
like people like Ted like people don't
talk about that when they because they
just like respect the hell out of
feelings like death makes you iconic
like in death there is ice tree on a
tree I don't know like at every VMAs
like video Vanguard like it's always
like Michael Jackson Michael Jackson but
then it summoned like literally years
will go by oh yeah wait he went on trial
for like child molestation yeah and
there's so much of it like it wasn't
like a one-off thing though it was a
whole it was systematic season yeah
there was a whole like infrastructure
around the child molestation it wasn't
just him like he was providing child it
weren't to molest yet other people
allegedly allegedly but no it's it's
really terrible but maybe because he
died before like you know everyone
decided that we're gonna call Hollywood
out on their [ __ ] yeah if he were like
it probably handle the accountability
now right if Harvey Weinstein died today
like he would not die an icon if he had
died like before the Ronan Farrow thing
even though everyone knew he was a
molester he would have still been like
one of the greatest yes movie makers
ever and now it's like no one cares to
uncover because like he's dead like
what's the point yeah it's just like so
weird because like when you think
Michael Jackson
you should think like on trial for
molestation you think like icon glittery
glove Vanguard Award moonwalk yeah we
would leave change of color risk it look
it's it's it's weird it's weird and I
thought right and like Kenny Ortega like
who works with children like is how good
I won yeah
it's happy to like to associate with him
also weird except I don't think there's
a lot of lines not Kenny Ortega like I
once literally searched his name on
antiques I barely likes you better not
be hurting these children juggy they are
blinds that could be Kenny Ortega but it
calls me a lot of people too but they
haven't been revealed yet but like
sometimes when Doug Cameron posts a
picture with Kenny Ortega like everyone
comments like yeah Kenny likes responded
she comes for them and like it's like
Kenny is the sweetest person in the
whole world like she doesn't have to do
that no she doesn't
so just something to think about yeah
and until innocent until proven guilty I
love Kenny Ortega but then if the same
logic would apply to Michael Jackson
because he was never proven guilty no
but like no one's come out against Kenny
Ortega like yeah so it would only be
speculation and guilty by association
mm-hm you know what 11:11 make-a-wish
Gucci bag Gucci bag Gucci bag douche bag
douche bag douche bag
bag but you bet thank you I think weird
like dude she has a red couch in it good
- delicious it's like a something in the
the oh yeah I do it's the part in
between I'm a no woman there's only a
couch on a man so it's the part in
between
it's an ABC someone told me that it's an
asphalt connector whoo I learned that in
high school like these boys in my grade
and um and I never forgot it cuz it's
genius little acronym and he hung his
child out the window like oh yeah
there's weird stuff so did Briggs meters
oh yeah but I mean I forgot okay next
story and a little bit of Health News
science tech final report says cellphone
radiation may cause cancer in rats but
not people so there was a 20 year study
conducted on cell phones radiation and
how they affect rats and they are they
are cancerous for the rats but they were
yes but the FDA is saying that perhaps
these findings should not be applied to
human cell phone usage because the
levels of radiation are very different
and like even though you can test on
racks like I'm not a rat no and also
like a rat is the size of a cell phone
so like what but so not exactly
comfortable I am the size of probably
like 75 rats yes look if you lined me up
it's not exactly comparable but I think
that the thesis is that there's cell
phones aren't harmless well and that's
why I member when everyone used to put
their phones in their bras and then it
became like taboo and any time I do it
been literally grabs it really and I go
please that's you lay on the bed with a
laptop on your stomach I'm your unit
cooks your sperm if you're a man or it
could cook you're over equal it boils
drugs the federal coaches your eggs
poached little scrambled they said
omelette the federal government's
National Toxicology program released its
final report Thursday on whether cell
phones cause cancer the final verdict
cellphone radiation may sometimes cause
tumors in rats at high continuous doses
but not in people report leaves open the
possibility that the kind of radiation
produced by cell phones might have the
potential to cause cancer but is it does
not answer the question of how that
might happen
the findings are unlikely to satisfy
many people yeah so it's like here you
go you spent years and years and tons of
money giving rats cancer and you still
don't know anything right it's like
these poor rats
even like rats but it's just like look
how many [ __ ] rats get to get cancer
to just to come up with a thesis that
you're unsure of right
thanks.thanks we need bruisers bill now
them more than ever more like bruisers
bill is so pertinent and it's like I'm
feel bad for rats I'm not gonna lie like
and when you like test makeup on it rat
like you're putting lipstick on a rat
again I'm not a rat like I don't have
rat skin yeah totally like it makes no
sense
you don't you do oh my god is you're the
best idea instead of animal testing cuz
like and a lot of beauty companies to
their right have their gotten rid of
testing on animals but like a decent
amount of the really big ones do and I
just came up with the best idea so we
should stop testing on animals because a
it's me and B it's like we're not
animals so it's like so whatsoever some
mouse got a rat a rash from this lip
gloss like it might be fine for me we
should test
I'm like violent criminals we put them
in prison so like they're they have no
use for their bodies anyway instead of
giving them like the death penalty like
they'll just get rashes and stuff or the
cream will work and it'll be super
hydrated totally like good idea animo
testing yeah but and you can off
like you can be like I want torture or I
want Beauty testing yeah or like death
row okay okay it's so like it's really
hard to get someone on did the death
penalty like it's very uncommon cuz like
it's a long process and then if you
actually do it there's like a million
years to overturn it but instead of an
appeal to like to spend life in prison
you can appeal to do any testing your
body to science like all different kinds
of it so you're not just also like
cellphone radiation testing right but
it's like with all this new technology
ever the argument is always like it
hasn't been around long enough for us to
know if it's harmful and it's like now
without those have been around twenty
years and we still don't know right so
thanks for this
inconclusive theory that took the lives
of like many rats money how much money
do you think they spent in the past
twenty years trying Trekkie to come up
with
try this the hope that I can prove their
hypothesis three identical strangers
there was money involved no it's like
they went through this whole study
literally did ruin people's lives just
if I took your life and then the study
was inconclusive and the study results
were never even released I think the guy
died like my doctor their project was
more effective oh my god
science their project it was a [ __ ]
billion you know I came in third place
what was it and if magnesium and
fireworks wait it was something about
fireworks yeah that's why people loved
it because my board was like so colorful
and bright and Alex Michelle was my
partner and we always talked about Alex
was all on the toast and we did it
really good me like tested magnesium
based fireworks versus other fireworks
and now she's a toaster I know that's
amazing we spoke about her so much we
turned her introducer I did I had to do
many science fair projects the only one
I remember is probably my worst one
because much like the ROTC you'd have
the same conclusion which is like how
does die Koch affect how to soda affect
your Billy you're inside and I don't
know if it was a regular coke first Diet
Coke but I like left like nickels and
pennies in them and like little cups of
soda and like see how they deteriorated
but then it's like at the end of the day
my insights aren't made of their
company's very true
so apples and oranges that's like in
toilet paper commercials when they put
like blue liquid on toilet paper it's
like my piece yellow so what does that
do for me I don't know okay next story
super interesting stuff in a seismic
move that deadlines
earlier this week revealed was coming
Netflix will boost the awards chances of
several contending films by setting
exclusive limited theatrical releases
prior to the streaming service releases
of a few of their movies so basically
Netflix is gonna put movies in theaters
instead before they go on Netflix just
so they can get in time for Oscar season
not even getting time but have more
consideration because like a movie that
you see in the movies that's what you
think of when you think of Oscars right
oh sorry so they'll be released on
Netflix eventually but first in limited
Seattle ready that's because we're
watching the award show in this Netflix
movie that three people have seen gets
all the awards no but I think it'll be
like maybe limit well let's see Netflix
is selectively evolving its first stream
in hopes that Oscar voters probably the
level of discussion in the present among
them how do me members on the subject
has ratcheted up particularly because of
Carranza Romo the participant in a
[ __ ] a how long are they gonna be in
theaters before we see them Netflix it's
like always coming up with terrible
ideas this isn't the worst idea ever
it's not but like good on them for
innovating and like having ideas and
like a part at least that our company
who like tries new things and like most
of them are bad but some of them are
good like when they gave us the
opportunity to skip the intro if you're
watching a series which I did tweet like
literally six years ago and it went
viral because Kevin Jonas reach me today
and then like a month later
looks at it and I can't help but think
that I had something to do with right
and now you don't have to watch all the
previous leads on if your binge-watching
a show right and it's great and like
they do good to smart things like that
but then they like are so focused on
their own original content we're like
only ten percent of it is actually good
and like this is like a fine idea but
it's like who cares and they're unsure
these movies like will make them no
money whereas like - all the boys I love
before is massive where's their Oscar
theater nobody really Netflix will give
more attention to a movie like this Roma
movie which is meant for the Oscars so
you know it's terrible it's enough
flicks moment it's a Netflix movie the
Oscars are annoying cuz like it's like I
see what like let's say I see 10 movie
new movies a year which I don't but like
I'm just saying 10 new movies a year
maybe one or two of them are like Oscar
contenders and they're like the worst
ones that I see yeah what do you thinks
gonna be the Oscars well actually
holidays is when most employees come out
but I haven't even seen a lot of like
commercials for anything a star is born
obviously obviously actually that's not
even so obvious because it's like it was
good and it did well you know so it
probably won't win an Oscar how much
money did it make I feel like everyone
saw it yeah and I feel like they're
always talking about box office number
and Brad look at her like I think is a
box office giant American sniper made
250 million dollars in like the first
weekend which is so great
Oh a star is stars more in box office
box office and numbers and you know if
they really were promoting box office
like winds greatest showman would have
won an Oscar just saying okay here we go
Margot that's for you domestically 153
million for in 106 million so a total of
259 exactly their bill but it depends on
what their budget was like if they spent
200 million at the movie the budget was
very small the budget it was here see
they used set times the class and Marion
stagecoach and they used Bradley
Cooper's dog production budget was 36
that's hello yeah worldwide was - 59 -
36 is you do the math because you know I
can - 39 - it's - 23 I think if I'm
right hold on now I want to do 39 - 26 -
59 - 36 okay I'll look it up what did I
say - 23 yeah - 59 - 36 36 no joke sorry
- 59 - 36 - 23 2000 okay yes so that's
good this is a great website box
Office Mojo calm I wonder what's doing
well these days watch we see oh here to
have this this thing called the showdown
okay so right now Halloween scary
I think it's spooky stuff I'm sorry no
this is I'm sorry no no no no world wide
right now ooh
Avengers infinity war two billion
dollars Wow this is for worldwide you
want to know Jess America or worldwide
um just America because I think Oscar is
really oh this is so interesting okay
the top movie of 2018 in America guess I
can't even think oh I'm Black Panther
yes seven hundred mil will they get
nominate for an Oscar no no Incredibles
- okay so number two was Avengers
infinity war [ __ ] I think out now 678
by the way it's all [ __ ] cartoons nah
cartoons comics Black Panther Avengers
Incredibles Jurassic world Deadpool like
I didn't see any of those paintings I
saw Jurassic world when Jurassic world
was was not that it was good you should
see it it's funny but it's number three
movie a great website here you know this
is her house schedule yeah I'll tell you
is how soon Aquaman okay after years of
anticipation Bohemian Rhapsody is set to
come out in 4,000 theaters which i think
is like a lot do you think that I think
that's gonna be an oscar movie for sure
yeah are you gonna see it sure even
though I know everyone's gonna kill me
and this is like on par with what I said
about Dave Grohl and um not
understanding the Foo Fighters Freddie
Mercury like um what band was here Queen
so what's it uh you're not met you're
not supposed to know him he's before
your time I just confuse between Queen
and Prince cuz like the Royals they're
both right okay here's what else is
coming out throughout November that I've
heard of dr. Seuss is a Grinch again I
know that but like Jim Carrey was so
good that I'm happy with the one that we
have right I'm a that makes me worried
keep going I haven't heard of crackers
coming out that's gonna be the most and
remember with Renesmee um we get Robin
Hood possession of Hannah grace I don't
know what that is
do you see the commercial for Nutcracker
Real Housewives of New Jersey of course
premium premium I love when Bravo does
commercials some are good some are
better than others like that one was so
Mamamia was not good but that was pretty
I mean I should check it out and here's
what's coming out in December the
silence I don't know what it is mortal
engines never heard of it
spider-man that's gonna do well Aquaman
Jackie put it in your calendar the 21st
even though we're gonna be Miami
hopefully we'll see you in Miami another
Deadpool that's how we'll celebrate
another [ __ ] dead well oh and Mary
Poppins with um Emily Blunt which
honestly like she is way too young to be
playing Mary Poppins and I would be like
she'll be great because she really
throws herself into any role but like
you can't play like Meryl Streep's
assistant in Devil Wears Prada and then
like seven years later play Mary Poppins
you know but Mary Poppins isn't supposed
to be very old
she's like mid-30s she's Julie Andrews
no but Young's really angry what's Julie
enters in my mind is always a
grandmother and here's the thing about
Mary Andrews like waddled out of her
womb like with grey hair you know and
ring Ellis
yes Anna's Queen of Genovia yeah of
course here's the thing about Mary
Poppins like I know I'm sure I'm gonna
see it and it's gonna be amazing I'm
sure it's gonna be so well done I know
but I feel like it's like supposed to
fill the hole in my heart that beauty in
the Beast of 20 what year is it 2016 and
greatest showman of 2017 filled and I
just I don't know if it's gonna be able
to do that you know like it's supposed
to be like Mary Poppins it's not but
maybe not cracker will be yeah it looks
a little spooky
like it doesn't look spooky still a
little spooky
it looks like [ __ ] The Lion the Witch
and the Wardrobe you know I never got
Chronicles of Narnia yeah I never got
into it that's what the vibe that
they're giving off him like I don't like
spooky stuff look at her she's in a
businesswoman dress she can be spooked
you'll tear it
if you get spooked by though you know we
should do it we should put a haunted
house
I'd be like sailing it um but like I get
so scared
well you're scared of everything I was
thinking literally yesterday about how
I'm like the worst person to be like
somewhat recognizable because if you
come up to me in the street you know I
don't see you approaching me like I will
scream and it's happened now on three or
four occasions where like literally in
bloomingdales are like a closed space
like I will scream you're easily if
someone just comes up to Jaime they're
like oh my god oh my god it happens all
the time it's like borderline
embarrassing and I can't control it by
the way aren't we past haunted
now like aren't they all closed because
Halloween's over now it's holiday season
yeah next year maybe we'll work up the
courage we should be doing escape the
room yeah but those aren't suppose to be
spooky really yeah but just the one
ariana grande engine difficult yeah it's
like you have to get the key the key
opens the door in the day I can't even
tell you how much I hate that [ __ ] like
can't I just stay home and I and then
I'm it's not a match so give me the key
no but it's like I don't need to get
through this door like and I just key
like makes you this puzzle on the puzzle
but the colors and the shapes and the
thing it opens the vault like it's so
stupid yeah you know I've never done it
I've been to Jekyll and Hyde though and
that was scary that was the og speaks
I'm still open yes we should have two
toasts event there we should it's like
now spooky season is over we need to
start thinking bout the holidays
remember March 21 12 of course the
greatest place ever of course we took we
were in a spaceship ones yeah we've been
to other planets
we're very cosmopolitan yes world
travelers what else should we discuss
before we wrap up for the week I mean
I'm not going to call you at this
weekend's yeah if you are seeing a
Broadway show I would love to go well I
was actually gonna go for under chopping
furniture shopping like outside of the
city if you wanted to home where my
guess there's no [ __ ] home goods in
the city by the way I left you yesterday
to go home guys I put in the new bear
checking on a one hundred and
twenty-fifth in Columbus I'm like I'm
not going all the way up there
and if I am I'm gonna leave the city and
go to like a big home goods right or
like is there not a Pier one Imports
there is but like I'm so over Pier one
because it's a facade and they only have
like amazing trinkets and it's also
seasonal and it's like oh I need
furniture not like pumpkin so you know
what I mean
yeah and I'll never be one of those
people who can pull off like a white
pumpkin display in my dining room table
as much as I would really like to be no
it's a nice it's nice to be that person
yeah and I don't know her right now
Zach's mom has a whole display on her
dining room table of the velvet pumpkins
a homemaker from Texas like that's
that's who can do it
not a girl who barely lives at home and
like has a dog that has a nephew sneak
test yeah it's like my priorities have
shifted in all sorts of ways by the way
how was the Oh yesterday after key gate
he was good I took him out and it made
me feel better that he didn't like the
second he hit the pavement like start
peeing he like walked like a couple feet
and then so it made me think he didn't
have to go so bad and we walked around a
little bit and then he had two extra
walks yesterday because I felt so bad so
he's okay he's forgiven me but mainly
forgiven his father which is what has
forget it that's what's annoying it's
like I was the last one to leave and the
first one to come back so he thinks I'm
the one who abandoned him without taking
him to the bathroom this [ __ ]
why wait check it out Oh seal swirling
twist smelly flies only swarm around
smelly people but like I showered last
night I wash my hair clearly me because
you smell good
they like the good smelling did you see
the biggest bug bites that I got no oh
my god well they're gone now they
weren't my story glad to know that you
watch so they always watch your stories
a kimblue them instead they were
literally wealth to huge Wealth's
interesting interesting those Texas buds
everything's bigger in Texas
Oh from the State Fair you got them no
from the sweat it was an outdoor man oh
I forgot you were also just in Austin
yeah um okay
I guess that's it I'm getting leg cramps
I mean I've been getting them so much
lately um hopefully eventually we was
you toast movie of the week Secretariat
if you ever watch it yeah let's watch it
this weekend okay maybe I'll have a
movie night okay at my apartment and
those sort of mine I'm actually now okay
let's [ __ ] fly [ __ ] it's okay next
week is gonna be a super fun week we are
here Monday then Tuesday i'm with joey
camasta teresa giudice and one sorry
Tuesday's my birthday sorry oh my god I
can't believe I just forgot about it
wow wow wow wow wow wow Bethany just Wow
Wednesday Theresa joey camasta thursday
man having fun co-host friday back we're
back together then we're off to Miami
for Olivia's bachelorette party where we
return on Monday so Monday we will
release just a podcast episode which is
a deep dive with Melissa Gorga and
honestly it was so easy and so fun like
I didn't feel like what was my next
question like she's just very
conversational and she loves the toast
and I love her love her Tuesday we're
here Wednesday we're Nashville CMAs
Thursday we are not here Friday is our
last show until after Thanksgiving next
Friday and then by the way after
Thanksgiving remember we are exclusively
streaming on YouTube so so make the move
so try not to freak out he's already
Facebook people yeah the money is at
YouTube and that's where we follow the
money right and I just I don't know even
just the whole experience I'm so done
with a Facebook page like I don't even
[ __ ] use Facebook anymore sacrum
coaster stuff like why would I think
there's nobody likes our Facebook page
but like there's more likes in our
Facebook group then they're on our
Facebook page
the group is supposed be an appreciation
for the page you know this doesn't make
sense fix a sense we hear you also we're
getting so close to a hundred hairline
we got a thousand followers yesterday if
we just get a thousand followers day
we'll be there in like ten days so
everyone please follow the morning shows
Instagram honestly I'm not even gonna
myself today except for my tickets are
available at girl with no job calm just
promoting the chose to Instagram like
more people listen to the podcast then
we have as listeners so like come on
come on and I'm not gonna promote myself
to say just the toast except to say that
um Claudia took the to disturb a and
it's actually like my most likely to
empty date which is that post and
reposted it right posted hmm
premium content as hell Takeo problems
is all I'm gonna say yeah that's all I'm
gonna say at the morning toast a girl
with a job a club with him job a pup
with no job a boy with no job at Club is
gonna drop a public in a job at Tiffany
Thornton thank you guys so much have an
amazing weekend
you